how much money did it take to bring
willem dafoe back as the green goblin
you may be surprised to hear that wasn't
the only thing he asked for
what
as fans debate where spider-man no way
home falls in the hierarchy of
spider-man movies one thing is clear
it's hands down the most ambitious
spidey flick to date without getting
into spoilers the film doesn't bother
itself with following formulas of the
past instead of having the web slinger
go up against a new baddie from the
comics the marvel cinematic universe's
peter parker has to face multiple
villains from previous spider-man
franchises it's an impressive feat to
get the original actors who played these
characters back after over a decade
since they originally put on the suits
what exactly did it take to convince
these actors to assume their villainous
personas once again in one interview
alfred molina who returned to play
doctor octopus jokingly kept it real by
saying for me it's just about the money
however willem dafoe had another reason
for returning as norman osborne aka the
green goblin although we're sure money
played a role for him too prior to the
release of no way home defoe made it
clear in an interview with mulderville
that if he were going to come back he
would do his own stunts we are who we
choose to be
these days it would have been easy to
cgi willem dafoe's face into a couple of
action scenes and call it a day but in
no way home the flesh in blood to foe
actually becomes a formidable presence
in fact many would likely refer to him
as the primary antagonist of the movie
seeing how the bulk of the destruction
comes from him and his influence on the
other villains and defoe's there for
much of the action doing his own fight
scenes at the age of 66. according to
dafoe that was an integral part of his
return he didn't just want to be a
glorified cameo he wanted the audience
to know he was there and doing his own
stunts as he told mulderville to do this
physical stuff was important to me in
fact one of the first things i said to
john watts and amy pascal basically when
they pitched it to me before there was
even a script was listen i don't want to
just pop in there as a cameo or just
fill in close-ups i want to do the
action because that's fun for me however
the need to do his own action extended
beyond just having fun he felt that
putting his actual body on the line was
integral to his process in getting the
best performance possible as he shared
in the interview it's really impossible
to add any integrity or any fun to the
character if you don't participate in
these things because all of that action
stuff informs your relationships to the
characters and the story it makes you
earn your right to play the character in
a funny way
you know how much i sacrificed after
seeing the movie fans would agree dafoe
was right at this point he's more than
earned the right to call himself the
preeminent green goblin and you can see
him in action now and spider-man no way
home
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]